die aufkündigung des pariser klima
abkommens durch die usa war ein schlag
ins kontor der ganzen welt in eine
verhöhnung der opfer des klimawandels
aber werden die usa vielleicht gar nicht
gebraucht und es gibt eine andere viel
effektivere lösung durch die das
fehlverhalten amerikas ausgeglichen
werden kann
geoengineering könnte eine lösung sein
noch stecken die technologien in den
kinderschuhen aber jetzt wurde in der
schweiz die erste kommerzielle anlage
weltweit zum recycling von co2 aus der
luft in betrieb genommen ob das die
lösung zur verhinderung der
klimakatastrophe ist jetzt endlich zum
science fiction herbst will kommt es ist
eine ziemlich verlockende technologie
eine anlage die nicht nur co2 aus der
luft filtert sondern das gas dann auch
noch für pflanzen nutzt und damit zwei
probleme auf einmal löst die
verlangsamung des klimawandels und eine
steigerung der nahrungsmittelproduktion
bis heute weil die gewinnung von co2 aus
der umgebungsluft als eigentlich viel zu
teuer
eine ausgerechnet amerikanische studien
bezifferten die kosten 2011 mit 740 euro
pro tonne utopisch hoch so wäre die
lösung von 42 viel zu teuer
jetzt hat aber die schweizer firma klein
birds mit ihrer technologie wohl den
gordischen knoten zerschlagen mit dem
verkauf befehl zwei zu marktpreisen an
ein gewächshaus soll die anlage
beweisen dass die technologie des drk
trinkt rentabel ist dafür wird bei
dieser ersten anderen kein strom zur
filterung benötigt sondern die
notwendige energie wird aus abwärme
gewonnen so entfällt ein erheblicher
teil der kosten zusätzlich ist die
filtertechnologie von kann das effektiv
und unkompliziert ein filter aus
porösem granular bindet das co2 mit
hilfe wird in der luft enthaltenen
wassers und chemischen bindemitteln ist
der fischer gesättigt wird er auf 100
grad erhitzt und wasser und co2
verdampfen das co2 wird abgespalten und
gesammelt noch ist die technologie am
anfang die anlage besteht aus 54 filtern
und kann die jährlichen abgabe von 200
pkw aus der luft filtern für die abgase
allein der berliner 13 millionen autos
werden
1000 solcher anlagen nötig klein works
kann zurzeit drei anlagen pro jahr
frauen und um nur ein prozent der
globalen co2 emissionen zu zeigen
während eine viertel million solcher
anlagen nötig 15% 25 millionen für
100% 25 millionen solcher anlagen moment
da finde ich jetzt gar nicht mehr
utopisch wir haben mehr als eine
milliarde autos auf der erde
da können wir doch locker mal 25
millionen solcher anlagen aufstellen
sicher wird er sich von jetzt auf gleich
gehen aber utopisch finde ich nicht vor
allem wenn es sich rechnet und damit die
pflanzenproduktion zum beispiel für die
welternährung verbessert werden kann
ich finde das ist mal so ein lichtblick
der wieder echt begeistert wenn sich
etwas neues tut dann habe ich euch
natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn er
kein video verpassen wollt dann tut mir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den auf die glocke dann werdet ihr
auch über jedes neue video informiert
hier geht es weiter mit dem wetterchaos
das jetzt durch den klimawandel begonnen
hat und ich sage bist dann bleibt dran
draufklicken wenn sie zu viert gespannt